[Musique]
bonsoir vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
c'est huit invités ce soir vous
entendrez philippe brillault maire et
conseiller départemental du chesnay et
l'a quitté vendredi 14 octobre le groupe
majoritaire du conseil départemental des
yvelines
il nous explique pourquoi vous entendre
aussi jean-claude fausse l'un des
membres du bureau de l'association de la
dame noire nous parlera du prochain
tournoi à montigny le bretonneux qui se
déroulera du 22 au 30 octobre prochain
on débute ce site huit invités avec de
la politique le maire et conseiller
départemental du chesnay philippe
brillault a quitté vendredi 14 octobre
le groupe majoritaire du conseil
départemental
nous sommes allés à sa rencontre pour en
savoir un peu plus
bonjour monsieur brio bonjour alors vous
avez quitté lors du conseil
départemental le groupe majoritaire
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi alors parce
que d'abord ce groupe s'appelle ensemble
pour les yvelines et il y a une semaine
le président nous a indiqué accélérer le
processus de fusion entre le 78 et le 92
donc ça veut dire que le département des
yvelines quelque part ne va plus exister
donc comment pourrais-je faire partie
d'un groupe qui s'appelle ensemble pour
les yvelines si nous ne sommes plus
ensemble pour les yvelines
moi je reste pour les yvelines et je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui le groupe n'est
plus ensemble bolivie c'est le premier
motif le deuxième étant alors le
deuxième c'est pourquoi je suis contre
la fusion du 118 et du 92 c'est parce
que nous avons été élus en mars 2015
avec un programme et avec une identité
qui s'appelle les yvelines je trouve que
vis-à-vis des électeurs on ne peut pas
prendre une décision seule juste les
élus sans d'abord voir le retour que
peut avoir
l'auscultation en tant que médecin de
nos habitants et de nos élus locaux vous
n'avez pas été consultés sur la question
non donc c'est à dire que c'est une
décision qui a été prise entre les deux
présidents qui nous ont été présentés il
ya un peu plus de six mois comme un
outil de collaboration et de
mutualisation
ce qui me paraissait tout à fait
intéressant de pouvoir faire une
économie et de pouvoir mutualiser des
moyens mais je pense que cette
mutualisation de moyens étaient les
prémices de cette fusion des six d entre
eux
le président du 92 et le président de 78
se partageant quelque part les fonctions
le président soit 118 et tente président
de toute une structure d'aménagement et
le président du 92 sur la gestion des
compétences autre que nous avons dans
les deux départements c'est pour ça
qu'il a été créé un établissement public
nouveau et pour recueillir les
compétences de ces deux quelque part ce
nouvel établissement public est quelque
part le nouveau département
d'accord mais qu'est ce qui vous fait
peur dans ce rapprochement on a beaucoup
à perdre nous habitants des yvelines
alors d'abord avant d'avoir peur j'ai
jamais trop la notion de peur je pense
que c'est surtout de se dire est-ce que
c'est pertinent
vous avez qu'à voir la taille du 92 et
la taille 118
on est deux départements complètement
différent on est géographiquement
parlant complètement à l'opposé et la
première décision qui a été prise
vendredi c'était le transfert de la
direction des routes toutes les routes
des yvelines vont être gérés maintenant
par le nouvel établissement public et la
direction va être à nanterre
donc quand je vois que le 92 découvre le
principe des paysans du 78 qui déneigent
c'est vrai que je vois pas très bien les
tracteurs aller déneiger de 92 et je
dirais que nous avons deux modes de
fonctionnement qui sont aujourd'hui
complètement différent la défense
ou est-ce que des yvelines donc on
pourrait dire les différences sont des
complémentarités
je dirais qu'avant de pouvoir le prouver
je demande qu'on valide bien déjà le
travail pour les yvelines
l'identité des yvelines et puis surtout
l'élément important ça a été aussi la
fiscalité le choix de vente est de 66%
la fiscalité sous couvert uniquement de
dire que c'était pour la perte de
dotation de l'état
on est largement au dessus donc moi je
crois que ce qui manque aujourd'hui au
conseil départemental des yvelines comme
d'ailleurs dans le 92
c'est une information réelle et une
participation de toutes les personnes
concernées ce qui aujourd'hui n'existe
plus vous avez quitté le groupe
majoritaire puisque d'autres vont le
faire et vous l'avez quittée c'est quoi
la suite maintenant pour vous la suite
pour moi elle ne change pas c'est à dire
d'être sur le terrain
à chaque fois que je peux en avoir
l'occasion au niveau du département pour
défendre des demandes mais par exemple
aussi sur les délégations je peux avoir
les différents établissements de santé
en tant que médecin en tant que
référence sur les phénomènes de santé
sur tout ce qu'il médico-sanitaires 1 to
le médico social c'est quand même la
compétence du département
donc je souhaite rester je dirais à
l'ecoute est remonté je dirais aux
instances du département ou des
départements
mes observations et puis après ils en
font ce qu'ils veulent mais il faut être
très clair depuis quelques mois ne
savons plus à grand chose
vous avez dit ne pas avoir voté pour
monsieur devedjian
mais pour monsieur est dédié oui
aujourd'hui il ya une difficulté à
discuter et que monsieur bédié c'était
vraiment pour lui dire là stop
non je pense que monsieur bédié à chaque
fois que je lui demande de discuter il
écoute il me reçoit
sauf la prairie minn udc va forcément
m'entendre fera donc une écoute et je
pense que son écoute et surtout fait
pour adapter sa communication pour
répondre ou à une opposition ou à une
contestation c'est d'abord une
contestation
il est très très fort en communication
et par contre c'est vrai qu'il ne tient
pas forcément compte de tout cela mais
il a aussi délégué à une administration
démission est ce que peut-être
l'administration et et la direction
générale ne sont pas peut-être un peu
brutale avec les élus c'est toutes ces
réflexions qu'il faut avoir les
départements sont importants il faut
garder la structure du département avec
une préfecture départementale
je pense que les conseils départementaux
devrait disparaître et
donner à profit les intercommunalités en
+78 interco versailles-saint-quentin
rambouillet menthe saint germain et
donner la compétence économique à la
région comme c'était prévu et puis
peut-être des collèges aussi à la région
il faut voir puis tout le social aux
intercommunalités
on veut faire des économies de
fonctionnaires et bien supprimant des
couches car y en a une de trop entre
l'intercommunalité et le conseil
départemental
peut-être que monsieur bédié le sachant
et et le pensant prépare peut-être aussi
l'avenir d'autres mères peut-être pense
démissionner vous allez attaquer une
sorte de positions non je ne pense pas
je pense que beaucoup d'élus du
département sont très ennuyée pourquoi
parce que contester c'est faire prendre
des risques sur son canton sur sa mairie
sur des subventions route c'est vrai que
le prénom du conseil départemental un
carnet de chèques et qu'il faut faire
attention pour par rapport à ça
moi je pense que j'aurai la possibilité
d'être le relais de sa lisez ce qu'ils
ont besoin de faire dire des choses donc
j'ai déjà eu des coups de téléphone j'ai
déjà eu ce week-end beaucoup d'appels
pour dire bah écoute
voilà c'est courageux de le faire je le
fais pas par rapport à moi-même je
dirais suffisamment de d'expérience
politique et d'ancienneté en politique
pour se dire que la peur n'est pas une
bonne chose pour le moyen terme et qu'il
faut toujours anticiper l'avenir voilà
et je pense que c'est pour cela que le
fait et par loyauté loyauté vis-à-vis du
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines et loyauté par rapport aux
électeurs qui m'ont élu pour les
yvelines et pour un programme et pour
finir c'est que la suite la suite et
vous avez des missionnaires maintenant
que la réaction
eh bien mon action sera continu pour
empêcher toute fusion entre le 92 et le
78 connexion sera permanente et
amplifiées tout et délibérations qui
auront rapport avec ça je voterai contre
et je pense même que je vais essayer de
lier un relais avec la population locale
et les élus locaux des yvelines pour
leur dire que voilà ce qui se passe et
qu'il faut qu'ils soient très force de
proposition auprès du président pour lui
dire stop
eh bien je remercie monsieur philippe
boucher en prix et on passe maintenant
aux échecs du 22 au 30 octobre à
montigny le bretonneux un tournoi
d'échecs est organisée par l'association
de la dame noire de la ville c'est une
association de la ville
c'est un tournoi un manque à bhl et
surtout accessible à tous écoutez les
propos de jean-claude fausse membres du
bureau de l'association
au micro de nicolas kirillovitch c'est
ce qu'on appelle un tournoi à norme
c'est à dire que pour les mettre pour
qu'ils passent au grade supérieur
c'est-à-dire maître international au
grand maître
ils doivent réaliser d'énormes en jouant
contre différentes nationalités 5
c'est pour ça qu'on fait un tournoi de
2 m par lesquels il ya plusieurs
nationalités on a un azerbaïdjanais un
bulgare un grec un maroc a et les
français et les jeunes français s'ils
font un bon résultat ils feront une
norme qui sera enregistrée et cataloguer
donc une norme c'est ça permet ensuite
on cumule les normes de devenir maître
et mettre ces deux grades de devenir
grand maître international ou maître
international pour l'instant ceux qui
sont maîtres simplement s'ils font cette
norme s'ils ont un très bon résultat
c'est que compliqué à expliquer ayant
joué contre 5 nationalités auront une
norme et quand ils en ont trois ils
pourront devenir maître international
plus le tournoi compte aussi un tournoi
pour les gens qui ne sont pas maîtres
pour tout le monde vous si vous voulez
jouer aussi est par contre ce tournoi
c'est la quinzième édition effectivement
donc tout le monde peut tout le monde
peut venir parce qu'ici vous avez une
licence vous pouvez venir participer
pour pour ceux qui qui concourent à des
choses sérieuses pour pour ce tournoi
racontez nous comment on prépare un tel
tournoi c'est comme n'importe quel sport
il faut s'entraîner des semaines des
mois à l'avancé ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ça c'est vrai qu'on connaît
pas forcément l'univers du du monde et
enfin le monde des échecs pas le monde
des échecs c'est très simple à chacun de
s'entraîner selon son niveau de
s'entraîner un petit peu tous les jours
mais à joueurs faibles comme moi je
m'entraîne de temps en temps et quand
j'ai le temps
mais c'est vrai que les grands maîtres
s'entraîne tous les jours c'est fait
pour tout le monde jeunes si ce n'est de
dessus notamment auprès des parents s'il
y en a qui nous écoutent à ce que vos
enfants aux échecs c'est fait pour tout
le monde chacun pourra jouer de façon
très intéressante en fonction de ce
niveau faut pas oublier que c'est un jeu
avant toute chose alors les enfants au
départ avant de faire de se concentrer
tout il faut ce qu'on appelle des
parties rapides eux ils jouent à toute
vitesse et le but c'est de
de gagner des pions contre l'autre
gamins et tout ils s'amusent et petit à
petit en acquérant de la maturité et
bien ils prendront plus de temps et je
rende mieux en mieux donc on peut
acquérir de la maturité et puis on peut
apprendre aussi la patience avec les
échecs voilà exactement le raisonnement
quelques informations sur le tournoi qui
va débuter le 22 octobre
on peut éventuellement venir regarder
c'est un sport qui se qui se regarde les
échecs ou alors c'est que pour les
pratiquants là alors ça se regarde vous
je vous invite à venir regarder si vous
connaissez un petit peu les règles vous
pourrez voir bon c'est pas aussi
spectaculaire qu'un match de foot c'est
clair mais vous pouvez venir regarder
par contre faut pas faire de bruit pour
ne pas déranger les gens qui se
concentre c'est la fin de ce sept huit
invités merci de nous avoir suivis et
surtout bonne soirée à vous
[Musique]